[Applaudissements]
nouvellement élu le président emmanuel
macron a déclaré de vouloir faire de la
moralisation de la vie publique
le socle de son action à la tête de
l'état il reprend là une expression de
son prédécesseur françois hollande qui
parlait lui en donnait 12 dans chaque de
moralisation à mention du languedoc de
l'assemblée nationale disait que l'on
vit actuellement un moment d anthologie
donc on voit à travers cette expression
une dizaine d'années le thème l'excitant
politique a le vent en poupe mais et
l'exigence éthique dépasse bien
évidemment le cap de la vie politique et
nous concerne tous et cette exigeante
confie macri fait particulière quand
elle concerne les responsables
politiques à lille on a délégué la coupe
but 2 assists et et à travers lesquelles
notre volonté s'exprime donc en théorie
la représentation politique et
allégations de pouvoir nécessite le
respect des principes de l'égalité des
citoyens et l'existence d'un lien de
confiance entre les gouvernants et les
gouvernés et ces deux principes peuvent
être ébranlée par les attentes à
l'éthique ou à la probité publique
comment
car ses attentes à la forme technique
peuvent faire que certains citoyens sont
plus égaux aux autres et peuvent
alimenter une certaine méfiance à
l'égard de l'institution
il me semble important que la crise de
confiance que nous traversons n'est pas
seulement le résultat d'une trop grande
malhonnêteté de la part de nos aînés en
réalité il est très difficile de savoir
si les responsables publics sont plus
cohérentes lui aujourd'hui qui ne les
paient si on sait par contre c'est que
telle est l'image que l'on a de la vie
politique
cette perception de corruption
l'évolution des méthodes des pratiques
médiatiques qui permet de réveiller de
plus en plus de ce scandale ainsi que
l'utilisation des accusations de
corruption par les hommes et les femmes
politiques pour déstabiliser leurs
adversaires
tous ces éléments centre une face de la
médaille de la crise de confiance
mais les effets nous montre aussi que
nous citoyens en devenant de plus en
plus éduqués
nous sommes aussi devenus plus critique
que la chasse aux promesses de campagne
mais réalisable génère beaucoup de
déception chez les électeurs que le
développement de ce qu'on appelle une
gouvernance à plusieurs niveaux
notamment avec la création de l'union
européenne près chez les citoyens
souvent un sentiment de des collections
avec les centres décisionnels et enfin
le développement de nouveaux problèmes
publics interrogés tête
de nos systèmes politiques à nous
protéger
tout ça pour dire que la promotion de
l'éthique n'est pas le cirad et ne
pouvait pas le devenir
souper de générer plus de frustration la
promotion de l'éthique publique est un
outil dont les responsables que les
types de se doit de se saisir de manière
réfléchie
mais quand on tombe par éthique
politique au concret pour un élu un
comportement éthique peut être le fait
de ne commettre aucune infraction comme
la corruption le trafic d'influencé la
fraude fiscale mais l'éthique publique
ou l'intégrité publique comme on
l'appelle de plus en plus souvent
dépasse de loin le cadre de la légalité
et la vie politique comprend énormément
besogneux plus que ce qu'on pense donc
pour un élu ou une élue
un comportement éthique signifie
également le fait qu'il ou elle
davantage par certains groupes sociaux
plutôt d'autres en échange d'un bénéfice
ou de la promesse d'un bénéfice qu'il ou
elle ne se sert pas de son mandat pour
s'enrichir qu'il ou elle ne se laisse
pas influencer dans sa prise de décision
par un v6 potentiels qui pourraient en
être tirées kg elle n'utilise pas son
influence pour avantager son parti
et enfin et c'est essentiel qui pour
elle soit guidé dans son combat par
l'intérêt général et non pas par des
intérêts particuliers
donc on a posé les problèmes mais quelle
solution peut-on apporter et quelles
solutions apporter à ce problème
aujourd'hui donc les pouvoirs publics
peuvent se saisir de ce problème de deux
manières principalement par la
répression
l'ascension du comportement abusif ou
par la prévention et la promotion du
comportement éthique et c'est en général
dans cet entrelacs que les organisations
internationales ont promu end contre la
corruption et la promotion de
comportements éthiques et que les états
s'en sont saisis donc cette promotion de
l'éthique publique se décline en
différentes approches alors oui nous
parler de la transparence du changement
des normes et des pratiques et enfin de
la formation de l'anthologie où la
transparence a été la première voie
empruntée par les organisations
internationales et par les états et la
transparence se justifie par l'idée
selon laquelle les adultes les atteintes
à la polytechnique sont le résultat
d'une asymétrie d'information entre les
citoyens et les élus
un meilleur accès à l'information permet
ainsi réduire ainsi les risques en
permettant aux citoyens de mieux
contrôler leurs représentants un ancien
juge de la cour suprême disait que la
lumière est le meilleur de l'entêtant
donc la transparence peut porter sur le
patrimoine et les intérêts
finances des partis politiques ou sur
les activités les groupes d'intérêt il
est intéressant de voir que les états ne
sont pas saisis de la transparence de la
même veine et pour prendre l'exemple des
systèmes des créatifs de l'éclairer sion
d'intérêt et de patrimoine la france la
suède et le royaume uni qui sont tous là
parlementaire a vanté une telle
déclaration
mais les systèmes faisant mis en place
pour contrôler ces déclarations sont
différents responsabilité de la mise en
place ne repose pas sur les mêmes
facteurs donc le royaume uni a une
longue tradition de déclarations orales
des intérêts dans le travail
parlementaire et l'idée de ces
déclarations en rade et qu'il est
important de savoir d'où parle aux
parlementaires quand ils prendraient les
cvl dans les années 70 ces déclarations
orales ont été complétés par des
obligations de déclaration écrite
et tout ça part d'un système
d'autorégulation par les parlementaires
votent par les années 90 le parlement
britannique a fait le choix de passer
d'un système d'autorégulation un système
d'autorégulation avec la création d'un
commissaire à l'éthique indépendant en
charge du projet ses déclarations et en
le parlement britannique n'a pas non
plus en permettant à des citoyens de
participer au travail de la commission
d'éthique qui jusque là muet
posez que deux parlementaires on voit
qu'il est protestant battu la suède a
mis en place son système déclaratif en
1996 et de la rendre obligatoire qu'en
jusque là les déclarations internes acte
volontaire et le parlement suédois a
fait le choix de mme instauré aucune
procédure de contrôle et de sanction
c'est donc cet artiste aime qui repose
intégralement sur l'autorégulation
al'inverse de la france qui a fait le
choix du contrôle de la régulation
externe par un contrôle administratif
depuis la mise en place de cette
obligation déclaratoire en 1988
depuis 2013 haute autorité pour la
transparence de la vie publique qui est
en charge de recevoir de traiter et de
publier les déclarations des abus il est
intéressant de voir que le système
déclaratif français se concentrent
principalement traditionnellement de cap
sur la détection de l'enrichissement
inexpliqué ce qui fit la création de ces
déclarations de patrimoine
alors que le système britannique et
suédois se concentre plus sur la
prévention des conflits d'intérêts
d'où l'intérêt portait pas la principale
anne sur les intérêts des aînés donc on
voit plein critique à laquelle la
transparence est censé apporter une
solution valide selon les éléments que
l'on demande aux responsables publics de
déloyale donc voilà pour la proche par
la trace partition plus récemment on a
vu apparaître des codes et des charte
d'éthique ou de déontologie
en france ici l'idée c'est de clarifier
la différence des comportements
acceptables et les comportements
considère pas comme les temps acceptable
et donc de clarifier et donc d'essayer
de faire changer les normes et les
pratiques de l'actif politiques ont ces
codes existe comme une réponse à ces
zones grises
je vends mes cassettes avant entre la
légalité et l'acceptabilité et le
dernier venu dans ses moyens de
prévention de la corruption et de
promotion des tic et la formation à la
déontologie et aux risques éthiques que
peuvent rencontrer les responsables
politiques dans leurs activités dans
leur travail quotidien
donc ici vous pouvez donc aller la
formation éthique est encore peu répandu
et peut accepter des parlementaires et
elle cherche la formation des os cologie
à réduire les risques par la
socialisation paris vienne en situation
donc elle illustre bien ce groupe pour
nom de l'intégrité capri la lutte contre
la corruption comme le dit le dicton
la chose juste même quand personne ne
regarde donc la promotion de l'éthique
politique s'institutionnalise depuis 30
ans en réponse à la méfiance
grandissante aux scandales à répétition
et à la pression internationale mais je
rappelle vient en conclusion que les
élus sont des responsables ne sont pas
les responsables publics comme les
autres et il est donc important de
garder à l'esprit la souveraineté qu'ils
incarnent et la séparation des pouvoirs
quand on met en place les systèmes de
contrôle qui sont ils
s'agissant de la transparence il est
également important de trouver un
équilibre juste entre dax et légitimes
des citoyens à l'information sur sur
leurs représentants et le respect de la
vie privée de ce dernier et pour finir j
insiste sur le fait que les politiques
et éthiques publiques sont un effort
bienvenue est nécessaire mais qu'elle ne
sont pas une solution magique à la crise
de confiance
elne en pleine leçon qu aucun des
ingrédients de la potion
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]